just moving on to some weather over the
weekend the remains of tropical storm
Cristobal are dumping heavy rains this
morning on a wide area near the Gulf
Coast the storm made landfall yesterday
south south of New Orleans hitting hard
in coastal communities like Waveland
Mississippi and it is now moving up the
Mississippi River Valley bringing a
chance of tornadoes Jade Cunningham of
our New Orleans affiliate wwl-tv is in
Mandeville Louisiana that's near Lake
Pontchartrain well good morning here in
Mandeville we saw about three inches of
rain and you can see that it definitely
had an impact on the area now
forecasters say in Louisiana we saw
about four inches total and in Florida
almost a foot a storm surge of up to
seven feet but this coastal Mississippi
neighborhood underwater floodwaters
submerged streets and cut off access to
several homes further east
officials say emergency workers rescued
dozens of stranded motorists parts of
Louisiana were inundated with 4 to 6
feet of water
the storms destructive path stretched
more than 500 miles to Florida flooding
streets in Jacksonville and spinning off
two tornadoes the first one touched down
Saturday in Orlando there were no
reports of injuries
the second hit Sunday afternoon south of
Lake City damaging trees in the area
crystal ball is the earliest third name
storm on record in the Atlantic Basin
forming just two days into the hurricane
season we still have 175 days left to go
of this season which is already
predicted to be more active than normal
Jade Cunningham reporting from Louisiana
about storm Cristobal that's a different
name for you